[Music]
you have a shaved head now and this is
for a movie that you just did with
Denzel Washington Mark Wahlberg yes I
play a navy commander - Mark Wahlberg's
Navy SEAL and it's called two guns a lot
of firing pistols and shooting RPGs and
it's a big blow em up movie yeah a lot
of fight scenes a lot of fight scenes
which is different for me because you
know I'm usually the The Prince and
Disney movies to get to ride away on a
white horse but here you're punching
hitting kicking I'm probably being
beaten is that right and being beaten by
both of them yeah yeah that couple of
fight scenes one with Denzel and one
with Mark and and I got the short end
the stick of both of them so yeah yeah I
would be intimidating you know you're in
a fight scene with Denzel Washington and
he's this iconic
no not at all
yeah no he when he steps on set you can
definitely feel his presence you know
and it's a whole it's a whole
choreographed fight scene and you kind
of you find yourself thinking well I'm
never gonna I'm not gonna disagree with
his ideas he's gonna come in so I'm
gonna pick you up I'm gonna throw you
over that say I'm gonna bend you over
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this and
you
[Applause]
it's a it's a hybrid action movie I
don't think that was a fight yeah I
don't think
[Applause]
probably notice there weren't any
cameras or I know this layer there were
no cameras we're in a restaurant in the
Bachelorette first of a very funny movie
people really loved this film and you
you shot some of these scenes in a strip
club
a real strip club real strip club yes
strip club
I believe those scores in New York you
endorsed that absolutely turn around
when you're there was some of the
strippers I believe that worked at the
establishment that we're in the movie as
well very good yeah so but I I don't
know for sure right
how's the food the food is great you're
joking but actually they were they
treated us to a very nice lunch there
then they cook a mean steak export that
scores professing people that go there
for the food board by the women yes I'm
over it
this is fantastic right right I come
here for the cuisine food we have it
here we have a clip here from
Bachelorette what do we need to know for
this clip um it's a movie what is it
what's being very it's a it's it's very
bridesmaids ish you know it's before the
night for a wedding and four guys four
girls gonna go nuts on the town and all
kind of crazy stuff happens and with
this clip is oh we're in the we're in
the limo on the way to scores yes so
back to scores let's take a look this
definitely Bachelorette like I'm
traveling backwards thanks to the
blindfold shows the Binda strip club
have you have I been to a strip club yes
yes Axios never have been duis
hence why I know that for the back.this
it's really just awkward what you get I
never know what can back me to do is
we're getting a lap dance in front of
other people
oh my god there's no reason to get
outraged you use words like hints I'm
with Joe on this one oh yeah I will not
let you kill fun on your own bachelor
party this is like negative fun you
don't get it if you meet the right girl
you don't do anything
I beg to differ I met the right girl
ended up in English so why don't you do
something about it like apologize never
got the chance
oh I smell a new profile Pig
[Applause]
[Music]
every show